okay so we're going to talk about the
universe as it is now not the early
universe but the universe that's
something like 13 billion years old and
it's doing something unusual
you look at distant galaxies by that I
don't mean galaxies nearby our own Milky
Way like the Andromeda galaxy so I'm
talking about galaxies that are tens of
millions of light years away from us and
you look at how they're moving with
respect to one another they're generally
moving away now that's that's not
unexpected because we know the universe
is expanding so if the universe is
expanding then it means the space
between galaxies is stretching but
what's going on that's unusual is that
it's not just moving apart it's moving
apart and moving apart faster and faster
so the universe is actually accelerating
so then you say okay well fair enough
the universe is accelerating what's
weird about that what's funny about it
is that if you just think of what's in
the universe we've got radiation and
we've got matter that make up us and
then we've got dark matter
we wouldn't actually expect that the
gravitational pull from those objects
would slow down that movement so that
the the universe is expanding because of
the hot Big Bang the energy from the hot
Big Bang but then gravity begins to pull
things back and we should expect the
galaxies to be slowing down but they're
not they're moving away faster and so it
implies that one of the things that
implies is that there's some form of
energy density being pumped in that's
causing it to expand this overcoming the
natural pull of gravity it's like an
anti-gravity and this has been coined as
dark energy so it's a bad name really
but it's but it's and it not only is
doing this it's dominating all the other
energy contributions in the universe
today in fact if you if you add up all
the types of energy that you could have
then you've basically got the radiation
in the universe you've got the matter
content in the universe and you've got
this dark energy and you've got the
possibility of the curvature of the
universe acting like an energy source
when you add all of these up they come
to unity - in terms of these funny units
the dark energy is about 70
percent so point seven of this
contribution is from this weird stuff
that we don't know we don't understand
the dark matter and making up about 27
percent as well so together they're
making up ninety seven ninety eight
percent of the of the energy density of
the universe that we just don't
understand what it is but today we're
going to talk about the dark energy so
one of the things that I've been working
on for the last few years is trying to
understand the source of dark energy now
it could be that the source has always
been there and it's been there
throughout the history of the universe
and it's just that it's come to dominate
everything today or in the recent past
by recent past by the way I mean within
the last seven billion years or so you
know we're talking cosmology here it
could be that it's been constant that
would be a term that would be a quantity
that has come known as a cosmological
constant and we can come back to that
another possibility is that it's
something that has been evolving with
time and that it has it was sub dominant
early on but perhaps it mimicked the
matter and radiation in the universe it
pretended it it was like matter and
radiation it followed the the the the
density of matter and radiation dropping
dropping dropping but for some reason
about seven billion years ago it came to
dominate everything and that those are
called generally come to the name of
quintessence theories where it's evolved
with time then there's possibilities
that it's not due to some energy source
at all that what we're seeing here isn't
either a cosmological constant isn't
some new form of energy but what we're
seeing is the first evidence the
Einstein's theory of general relativity
needs modifying and we're seeing that it
needs modifying on these large scales
there's size of the universe the
observable universe and these are called
modified theories of gravity and so
these three possibilities are all being
actively pursued as a way of
understanding the observation that the
universe is accelerating
des and I've been involved in in kind of
all three of them trying to come up with
models which try and mimic these it
doesn't have to be that's right if in
fact so of course when we say in Stein's
got it wrong it's a bit like he's got it
wrong
perhaps on these largest scales he's
clearly brilliantly correct on solar
system everything within the solar
system is beautifully explained by
Einstein's theory of gravity in fact to
be honest if I say it quietly
pretty much everything on even
cosmological scale seems to be
brilliantly explained by Einstein's
theories of gravity so any modification
would have to be kind of quite small but
it could be that we just need these
small modifications in which case we
don't need these new exotic forms of
energy to energy density to explain it
as you say it's due to some change in
the gravity of a the curvature of the
universe that that's leading to the
observations that the universe appears
to be accelerating well I've just been
thinking about that because I don't
think dark energy is such a great name
it's there's lots of things that are
dark then it's not particularly that
that's special lots of things have got
energy and that's not really that that's
special but the thing that makes dark
energy the important quantity to it is
is that the pressure it has is negative
it's got a negative pressure and that
means it actually causes things to push
apart that's the way that you can
imagine it so so it's kind of like you
can think of it as a bit having a bit
like a tension and associated with it
and and it's smooth that's the other
thing about it it's it's a very smooth
components through it's pretty uniform
throughout the whole universe so
something like a smooth tension might be
a
be a better thing to have rather than
there rather than dark energy just move
tension yeah I guess the problem with
that name is it doesn't it doesn't
allude to the fact that it makes it
sound like it like we might know what
we're talking about all that we know is
that when you write down the equations
Einstein's equations and allow for
something that can have a negative
pressure it will do the job for you
that's the clear so a cosmological
constant will do that for you as will
these concocted models that you have
these quintessence models they will do
it for you and then of course you can
you can also use your modified gravity
and you and the modifications will do it
for you as well there is one other thing
that that will that can effectively do
it for you which is is less in favor but
hasn't been completely ruled out and
that is maybe the universe isn't as
smooth and as uniform as we thought
maybe and we knew our very structure in
the universe right we know look at you
and I we're quite different and even
though you're down the gym and I'm down
the gym we're still quite different so
there are structures out there we know
that there are that galaxies are kind of
clustered together on in filaments and
those filaments kind of surround voids
or voids where there is lower density
than on the average but the the thought
is that as you get to bigger and bigger
scales in the universe that that the
distribution of those voice becomes a
bit more uniform and and there that
their effect drops off giving you this
net homogeneity things are very smooth
but maybe that's not the case you know
maybe actually the universe is is a
homage inhomogeneous it's not
homogeneous nice and smooth on large
scales and if it's in homogeneous then
and we happen to be living in a void in
a in a region that's got a lower density
than
on average then we would actually
perceive the universe to be expanding at
a different rate from outside and it
could be that that's what we're seeing
you know the effect of this acceleration
is and that's what an acceleration is
you're seeing a different rate here
compared to here and the effect of the
acceleration is just that but because
there are so many that's probably not
the case and the reason why it's not the
case is is because of the the the fact
that we can measure different things in
the universe and from it infer something
about the distribution of the matter so
we can measure the microwave background
radiation we can measure the
distribution of the hot and cold spots
in the microwave background we can
measure the distribution of galaxies and
when you do in particular the microwave
background and look at the distribution
of the of the hot and cold spots it
becomes clear that in order for this in
homogeneous model type of models to work
then you need to be in a very special
place in this void in fact you need to
be very close to the center of the void
and then you begin to ask well why is it
I would be very close to the center of a
void I could be anywhere in this void so
there's some high degree of fine-tuning
going on in order for you to explain the
apparent acceleration of the universe
from the idea of these in homogeneous
distribution of matter so it's it's kind
of being it's under under threat as a as
a as a model but it hasn't been ruled
out yet but it's it's certainly very
fine-tuned if it is the cliche dark
energy is this like some kind of
particle or field that can't be measured
is it is a thing is a thing with mass or
no mass it has I've got energy that can
be measured in joules or as this like is
dark energy just a label and shall I get
idea shall I get my cup of get my cup to
show you see how much energy there is
okay if you just hang on I'll go and get
it
what a shame
Hannah's taken it yeah I think I
understand it to university anyway she
had a dark energy cut but his for this
cup here it's about this size this cup
has in it about it I think it's a Yocto
gram of 10 to the minus 24 joules of
energy of dark energy because that
energy is smooth right it's throughout
the whole universe so it says it has got
an energy he's got and it's got an
energy density and so you can work out
how much end is using a cup and I think
it's about 10 to the minus 24 joules
which is not not a huge amount but it's
it's it's there so what makes it spent
you said what is it well we don't know
what it is and that's why we we try lots
of things that can mimic its effect the
key ingredient isn't particularly that
it's got an energy that's lots of things
have got energy matter has got energy
radiation has got an energy associated
with it that doesn't make it that
doesn't make the end of the universe
accelerate it actually slows down the
universe but what the things that have
energy also often have pressure and now
we usually think of pressures of as a
positive quantity you think of particles
banging against the surface of a
container creating a pressure pushing
out and that's that's a positive
quantity so radiation has India in the
early universe relativistic rate
particles have a radiation pressure
which is a third of the energy density
dark matter particles and the particles
that you and I are made up of they're
called dust particles written as the
general name given to them they've got
basically no pressure because they're
hardly moving they're moving
nonrelativistic so you think of putting
some dark matter or some baryons that we
are made of in a in a in a tin and
they'll hardly hit the side of the tin
there because they're moving so they
don't create a pressure so that's got
zero pressure or very close to zero
what makes dark energy special is that
the pressure it has actually is negative
and and so it's it's you need you need
something that can that can produce have
a positive energy density but have this
negative pressure that's acting in the
opposite direction to what you might
imagine and there isn't any standard
stuff does that the stuff that you and I
are made of the particles that you name
enough just does not do that you need
something more a bit more exotic and the
Thoth the the the two favorite ways of
doing it are basically to use what the
particle cosmologists lives to use which
is a scale of field and a scalar field
has both a it's an object that's got a
value everywhere and it's its energy is
made up basically of a kinetic energy so
the kinetic energy of motion of that
object and the potential energy that's
sort of telling you at any given point
in space and time and time what's its
potential associated with it
now if it turns out that potential
dominates over the kinetic so the
kinetic energy of the field it's
oscillating around is small compared to
its potential energy then it will have a
negative pressure and it can cause a
kind of a repulsive effect in terms of
causing acting against gravity and and
so that's what a quintessence scenario
will do for you you work in a regime
where the potential dominates over the
kinetic energy and it will give me this
negative pressure
it's what a cosmological constant does
in fact in a cosmological constant is a
unique case where the the energy density
is exactly minus the pressure so they're
balanced that they're equal in magnitude
but opposite in sign and that has an has
the same effect the data suggests that
the universe is perfectly consistent
with the cosmological constant so that
the acceleration of the universe has
been driven by something that looks like
a cosmological constant in actual fact
just recently there's a set of death
in coming out if you look at the plank
and microwave background data if you
look at people the data coming from
people that have looked at some
supernovae that by the way is the way in
which we infer what the universe is
doing you you I'll come back to that if
you look at the their data they're
actually finding that the pressure is
actually less than and the pressure is
less than the energy density the - okay
what they're finding is that when I
divide the pressure by the energy
density for a cosmological constant that
number would be minus one if I do the
same for ordinary matter that number is
positive so the pressure is a third of
the energy density for radiation the
pressure is zero for dust for a
cosmological constant the pressure is
minus the energy density so pressure
divided by energy density is minus one
for a quintessence scenario you find
that the pressure evolves down towards
minus one it it begins to look
eventually like a cosmological constant
but there seems to be some tentative
suggestions that actually the pressure
divided by the cup the energy dose is
less than minus 1 so that's lower than a
cosmological constant would give that's
a weird scenario and it it's probably
not going to last that I imagine the
data will push everything back up
towards a cosmological constant but at
the moment there's a slight pressure to
what in the data so yes I think it might
be less than minus 1 that means that the
universe is actually not just going to
is going to end up with a big rip it's
called a phantom scenario and in the
Lyne there'll be a future singularity
where it will just tear apart because
it's expanding so rapidly that first of
all the galaxies begin to move apart
rapidly and then the matter within the
galaxies begins to break up under the
influence of the expansion of the
universe so they all break up and then
eventually the fabric of space-time
itself will split that's the idea it's
not good
that's not gonna do much further no
London or carry on I mean just around in
London that'll be no problem gasps easy
yeah it's that galaxy being pulled away
from us or pushed away from us no that's
a good question
the there's the dark energy is driving
the expansion of the universe so it's
driving the relative size of the
universe so this is so in that sense I
would say it's it's it's pulling it's
pulling the the galaxies apart you could
also think of it as pushing them apart
as well though but I I think I I think I
would no actually I think I think of it
as pushing the galaxies apart because to
be pulling it apart you need something
outside of it to be doing that and the
the the dark energy is part of the
overall system of space time and matter
and energy density and so it's integral
to it so it's affecting the space time
it's not outside of it
pulling the space-time so I'd say it's
effectively pushing pushing them apart
through its come through the effect it
has on the overall size of the universe
that's a good question I hadn't really
thought about that yes it's everywhere
it's it's there's simply very little
variation in it in fact no noticeable
variation today it's in it so a constant
like a cosmological constant would do
that it's just but the same everywhere
that's a very good question so the the
the key thing I think you need in
cosmology really is not a single there's
usually not a single smoking gun one of
the benefits that you have in cosmology
that you don't have necessarily at the
Large Hadron Collider they back in some
sense of complementary and the Large
Hadron Collider
it's huge asset is the fact that it can
produce the same
situation millions you know six hundred
million times a second collisions are
occurring so six hundred million times a
second you're producing the conditions
of the very early universe ten to the
minus eleven seconds after the Big Bang
you can't do that in cosmology it's gone
but what you can do is you can probe the
different epochs of the universe using
different sets of data so for example
the Cosmic Microwave Background is
really probing the universe as it was
three hundred thousand years after the
Big Bang is telling you what the
universe looked like as those photons
decoupled from the matter but on the
other hand if I look at say the
distribution of galaxies are of clusters
of galaxies that's telling me about the
universe much later on a few billion
years later if I look at the abundance
of the primordial elements in the
universe that's telling me about the
universe much earlier than a few minutes
after thee and Big Bang so that there
are these different epochs that I can
probe I can look for example the
distribution of the supernovae in
distant galaxies that is giving me a
snapshot of how the universe is
expanding at different moments and by
each of these that the distribution of
the galaxies the distribution of the hot
and cold spots in the microwave
background the relative distance between
this distant supernovas they all depend
upon how the universe is expanding they
that means they all depend upon the
source of dark energy that you've got
whether it's a source that's constant
over time or whether it's a source
that's varying over time so what you
really want to do is get as much data on
these different epochs as you can and
see what models they're all consistent
with and that's the that'll be the key
ingredient it won't be that the
microwave background will pin it down
for me all the clusters of galaxies will
pin it down I will need all three and
I'll have to be able to bring them
together and find which of the if any of
the models best fits the the combined
total and that
we'll be the way that we'll try and do
it so currently one of the key things
that's out there they're out there are
specialist telescopes being built and
now working there's the dark energy
survey which you're knotting and we're
part of and that it's a know that it
says what it's going to do on the 10
right it's going to it this is trying to
probe for evidence of you know trying to
find out what the dark energy is and one
of the ways it will is going to try and
do it is by looking as deep as it can a
distant supernovae in distant galaxies
and why that could be really useful is
that we've just said the universe is
accelerating today and we've just said
what's the consequence of that we've
said it's going to rip everything apart
okay ventually if it was to carry on but
if I turn that about if that if the
universe always accelerated then we
would have never formed structures right
the atoms in the universe would never
have had a chance to pull together under
gravitational attraction because the
acceleration would have pushed pulled
them apart push them apart too quickly
for gravity to pull them back so we know
the universe can't have always
accelerated so that means there's an
epoch there's a time in the in the
universe where it went from a period of
not accelerating to accelerating and
this is the epoch which the dark energy
survey is going to be trying to probe
because it can look deep enough into the
universe to look at the distribution of
the supernovae in galaxies at that scale
now if we can get enough information
about that period then what we will be
able to do hopefully you start
discriminating between the various
models that try and explain dark energy
like the cosmological constant like a
quintessence model like a modified
gravity model because they should all
have slightly different ways in which we
leave the decelerating period that's
called the matter dominated era and
enter the accelerating period so that's
one way for example that we will try and
test these
this dark energy is everywhere you're
saying it's in this room it's it it's in
that cup so yeah what is it about dark
energy that makes you unable to detect
it or measure it or be able to prove
it's year because it's hardly interacts
with anything in the sense of right on
the Sun it's a bit like gravity it's not
like gravity in the sense gravity sucks
and this isn't but gravity in this room
is you know very difficult to pin down
and if you had very you know it's big
influences on big scales with massive
objects and dark energy is doing the
same thing you know but just because you
and have put on a bit of weight over the
last few months and you know you've
grown you you can't put it down to the
accelerating universe right dark energy
has absolutely no impact on us in our
everyday lives because the forces that
are binding us together I'm much
stronger than the thought than the dark
energy which is trying to pull us about
the dark energy here is trying to pull
us apart that's true but it's completely
negligible compared to the forces within
our bodies which are keeping us together
and the force of gravity which is
keeping us on the earth so it becomes
very difficult to determine it in the
lab but I am involved in an experiment a
proposed experiment which is going to
try and do that it's going to try and
look for various forms of dark energy by
which are called chameleon fields so
this is one of these quintessence type
models which where the dark energy can
its contribution can change this
particular model is I'll just explain it
briefly it's very nice because the the
effect of the chameleon field which is
going to be my dark energy field depends
upon its environment so in a you know in
an environment where it's in the
presence of lots and lots of matter then
it it's a heavy field it doesn't move
very much it doesn't do very much in the
presence of very little matter like on
these very large scales these
cosmological scales the field is
extremely light
and then it can actually it has a
negative pressure associated with it and
it acts like a effective cosmological
constant it drives the acceleration so
we've got a difference right we've got
if we had if I have a very light density
of matter it it's a very low density of
matter the field is very light if I have
a high density of matter the field is
very massive and it reacts to the
density so what this experiment that is
that we're proposing with a colleague of
mine at its own uh team Clare borage and
then with Ed Hines at Imperial is we're
going to have an if it works out we're
going to have a comp make a condensate
so bose-einstein condensates you know in
the lab in a in a chamber so you've got
this gas of in the molecules in the in
the in the chamber and then we're going
to separate them you can move them apart
and we're going to and remember it if
the if this field is present we've said
it's everywhere okay this chameleon
field is every well at the moment it
won't do anything special the two
condensates are very similar if I have
the same value in each of the condensate
but imagine now I bring a really massive
source something really massive close to
one of the condensates so that means
that this condensates is suddenly
feeling a much bigger density it could
be a heavy object okay it all be that
would be ideal if it was some very
massive heavy object then then this bit
of the bo-zone remember I've split the
bose-einstein condensate let me do it
big I split it in a big way here so
there's one bit here that is now feeling
this big source so it feels more massive
its density has increased but this one
is still not experiencing that source
but really what the chameleon field does
it reacts okay it reacts to the local
density so it will feel much heavier
here than it does here and so it will
change its profile and what you can then
do is you can quickly bring the sources
back and the two values of the chameleon
field will kind of interact with one
another and we'll see like in like in
what's known as an interferometer you
can see interference effects
from this chameleon and and that would
be a way of testing for the chameleon
model of dark energy and that that is a
lot that we can do in the we're going to
try and do in the laboratory this
matter-dominated period yes
no it could have been present it just
must not be dominant yes yes yes that's
a good question
yeah so when you've got em when you've
got radiation and matter in a universe
that's expanding its contribution to the
energy density drops that's really
straightforward to understand but let's
just remember what we mean by energy
density we mean the the energy stored in
a given volume so and that's what a name
that's what the density is it's per unit
volume so if you imagine the volume has
been our universe okay and I have a
given number of particles these days are
matter maybe I've got ten particles and
initially the volume is maybe you know
this big so I've got ten particles in
this volume so the energy is is this
number of particles divided by this
volume so it's maybe quite high
now I double the size of the box so the
number of particles has remained the
same I've still got ten the energy has
not changed I've got ten but the box has
doubled in size so it's volume has gone
up by a factor of two cubed eight so the
densities dropped by a factor of eight
and if I double it again it goes down
again by the cube and so you can see
that that matter in an expanding
universe its energy density inevitably
drops okay right so dark energy because
of its nature is its energy density can
remain constant all the way through and
the models that I've listed that we're
putting forward in terms of these
quintessence models they are such that
they will act like radiation on matter
so they they initially will drop but
they'll have some feature about them in
their potentials which eventually means
they come to go constant and they
eventually come to them
in it so there will always be a tipping
point as you said where the matter has
to drop radiation actually has to drop
even faster radiations probably worth
just mentioning so I imagine I've got a
photon of light and again I've put it in
this box okay and I've got a photon of
light in this box the universe expands
so the Box doubles in size this photon
it stretches because that's what the
universe it will stretch though it's a
its wavelength will double okay well we
know that the energy goes as one over
the wavelength energy in light goes as
one over the wavelength so if you double
the size that the wavelength its energy
has halved and so now you've got the
energy has gone down by a factor of two
from the radiation but it's gone down by
this factor of eight from the box so in
fact it goes down by a factor of sixteen
2 to the power 4 so the energy in the
radiation drops even faster than the
energy in matter so the early universe
is one where you're initially dominated
by radiation and matters sub-dominant
but the radiation density is dropping so
rapidly that eventually there's a
tipping point there that's a very famous
epoch that's called matter radiation
equality where they match radiation
keeps dropping matters drops off less
quickly but now eventually this there's
another tipping point it's somewhere
here where the dark energy comes to
dominate and that's that's ER yeah
that's right so unless this if it's if
it's a pure cosmological constant that's
will be the outcome the universe will
just keep expanding it'll accelerating
and goes into what's known as a dessert
to sitter expansions and exponential
expansion and yeah the first of all that
what will happen is the galaxies will
drift apart
you know because they've been pushed
apart so the first thing we will notice
is that will
all the distant galaxies just moving
away from us and eventually we won't see
any there won't be any in our vicinity
so that's pretty sad but and then within
our own galaxies the stars will begin to
move apart and we'll see them drifting
out and then within our own we won't be
here by then of course but within our
own solar system that will happen and
then eventually they they act the
molecules and the atoms will themselves
break up but most people I think believe
that this is probably a transient
feature and that what we're going to see
is that there'll be some decay of the if
it's a field a scale of field
responsible like a quintessence that
will decay just like the decay and
inflation which then allows the universe
to reheat that there will be some decay
and we'll move back into something like
a matter or a radiation dominated
universe again zero degrees you walk all
the way around and you come back to 360
degrees with a straight string that's
not quite right the string sort of cuts
out a bit of space so when you walk
around it makes your space conical